[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute gibt es einen grundriss tombolas
ich werde euch zeigen die schwimmer
rollen hersteller wollen können wir aus
dem asiatischen laden da haben wir super
gerne gegessen aber ich machte auch
mittlerweile richtig gerne selber sehen
das ist wirklich super einfach und zwar
so einfach dass wir auch von euch
wirklich nie danach machen kannst sommer
rollen wie seht ihr jetzt vor mir dass
es in reispapier eingewickeltes gemüse
gerne auch mal mit fleisch oder mit
fisch zum beispiel ich hatte hier die
variante mit gemüse und die gattung
hähnchenfleisch und gemüse ist aber wo
also gehabt da wirklich noch ein
bisschen rohkost in reispapier es ist
wirklich super lecker sehr gut und sehr
schnell zu machen
vor allem finde ich ist es auch schon
mit party oder auch gestern rezept denn
man kann die sachen zu bereiten und
vorbereiten und am tisch kann dann jeder
einfach selbst bestimmen wie er seine
eigene firma rolle finden möchte mich
bis heute was ich darin eingewickelt war
ihr könnt auch die flut hatten immer
weiter verändern aber heute früh die
sally version für die sommer rollen
traurig karotten avocado hier habe ich
eine rote paprika vielleicht kurzen 16
salat frische minze und koriander
hier habe ich ihn hinter glas nudeln und
reis lancieren ich kümmere mich jetzt
zuerst einmal um das gemüse und fang mit
mir den karotten als untermieter bietet
einfach alles schön fein geschnitten ich
werde in stücke schneiden was ihr in
lange stifter weil es einfach sein
wirklich super hübsch aussieht
und da könnt ihr wirklich nehmen muss
ihr möchtet ich habe hier meine auswahl
aber ihr könnt doch gerne ergänzen oder
auch weglassen
[Musik]
ja
endlich
[Musik]
richard ganze gemüte vorbereitet die
münster und den koriander den suff
später noch ab jetzt in die glasnudeln
an der reihe
glas modulen bestehen aus verschiedenen
staaten und zwar ist weiß wo kronen
strecke drin meist stärker und caparros
stärke und die werden nach dem garen
durchlässig glasig und deswegen haben
sie auch den namen habe ich hier wasser
bereits aufkochen lassen
schaltet den hersteller aus und
glasnudeln einfach rein und in ein paar
minuten jetzt schon schön durchsichtig
in ein paar minuten sind sie dann weit
und stimmte dann hier heraus die
schlaflosen sind jetzt schön weiß jetzt
geht es auch schon ein bisschen fiel bis
auf
jetzt werden sie jedenfalls kurz abgeben
es gibt wie hier in ein schälchen und
vermisse sie jetzt mit etwas öl
denn ansonsten fangen sie gleich an zu
kleben und da gebe ich jetzt einfach
geschmacklich dazu passt dass entweder
meldeten sich die hier abkühlen und kann
gleich die sommer rollen schon
zubereiten aber zuerst einmal weil ich
die app nutzloses zubereitung zum rhein
kippen und weil ich hier mal die flut
haben
für die etwas traurig 130 gramm cremiger
erdnussbutter
hier habe ich jeweils drei esslöffel rum
und sojasauce ein stück ingwer und
knoblauch denn das eine limette und dann
noch dementsprechend wasser die erste
tote könnte jetzt in einem mixer
zubereiten ich machte die themen im
staat mit bahn oder ihr könnt auch zum
beispiel ingwer und knoblauch pfeffer
einreiben und alles einfacher verrühren
jetzt kommt einfach alles zutaten hier
rein und werden miteinander vermischt
bisschen wasser und war mir bei so viel
wasser dass eben mit dickflüssige sauce
entsteht wie weh das tut noch die töne
seite müsse einfach selbst bestimmen die
konsistenz haben möchte
[Musik]
damit reiße blätter und wenn wir uns
jetzt mit freunden zum beispiel zweifeln
da machen wir das einfach so dass jetzt
so einfach alles auf den tisch kommt
auch im schälchen mit wasser und danach
jeder bei einer sonderrolle einfach
zusammenrollen und im prinzip füllen
somit er möchte ich mache das hier
einmal für euch
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier die reis
blätter krems lauwarmes wasser und
tauchte jetzt hier einfach kurz ein und
durch die feuchtigkeit wird es dann
gleich schön weit weg sie nur ein
bisschen ab und lass uns einfach kurz
ziehen und unsexy zusammen und spricht
nicht
und jetzt werde ich die freistehende
mitte einfach belegen
ich fange einfach irgendwo an
[Musik]
ich hätte ja auch meine hähnchen
streifen und frage der hähnchenbrust
genommen und einfach mit etwas wasser
und gemüsebrühe aufkochen lassen
liebes durch war fast dann wieder
weggenommen die gemüse- und hühnerbrühe
einfach getrunken dieser nicht super
lecker und jetzt jedes fleisch
abgelassen und auch geschrieben
[Musik]
kann
dann und nur dann vorliegt
[Musik]
damit jetzt nicht an meinem teller
anheben könnten verleiht ein bisschen
mit öl bepinseln
ich mag mit wachs service bringt
so wird jetzt weitergebaut
[Musik]
opel feiert im sommer wollen jetzt auf
und jetzt nimmt ihr sie einfach und
funktionäre erdnusssoße und spd aus da
der mobile ist leider gerade zum problem
nicht da ist macht das nicht vor
ich habe eben schon einige gesten und
die sind wirklich super lecker das ist
jetzt natürlich meine version das heißt
wenn ihr eine andere version machen
wollten schlimmsten beispiel oder
kanälen drin oder was auch immer
dann könnt ihr ihn natürlich auch gerne
machen auch bei uns von asiaten noch mit
dabei ist eine leckere floss fakt ist
lecker weil der akku sehr lecker findet
dass in auschwitz mit drin die mag ich
gerne aber viel stroh sich einfach nicht
das was ich gerne immer es deswegen ab
und zu geht ich habs jetzt heute wegen
auch nicht zubereitet aber falls ihr
auch möchtet könnt ihr ihn natürlich
auch noch mit rein nehmen wird ob ich
das nicht so präsent nach macht ist
wirklich ein super sommer rezept vor
allem weil man einfach viel davon essen
kann also ich kann jetzt den kompletten
zähler auf essen zu 56 stück auf jeden
fall bin auch popstars danach und weiß
vor allem dass ich noch richtig gut ist
ein gesundes weg es hat also falls ihr
das rezept nachmachen wort wolf gibt
auch fälle - blog.de da steht doch mal
meine flughafen wie gesagt ihr könnt
variieren und ich wünsche euch jetzt
schon mal ganz viel spaß dabei und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]